Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it.
Bruno has been building his own amusement
park in the woods of Italy for the last 40
years.
Ai Pioppi is a restaurant in Battaglia, Italy
that he opened in 1969 and when he couldn't
find a welder to make some hooks that he needed,
he taught himself to weld.
Bruno started creating these rides to build
surrounding the restaurant and to date they
include zip lines, roller coasters, tilt a
whirls, swings, and slides for both children
and adults.
Kate McGwire makes beautiful sculptures out
of bird feathers such as this one from rooster
feathers, one made from Mallard feathers,
a combination of dove and swan feathers, and
this one from crow feathers.
And she says she likes using well known materials
in an unexpected way to play with the senses.
Embodying Ethics: Endangered is a project
by Rohan Chhabra where hunting jackets transform
into animals under attack from illegal poaching.
And he's hoping to raise awareness for this
issue.
Some of the jackets include the Saiga Antelope,
Asian Elephant, Gorilla, Rhino, and Tiger.
Mike Iverson of Blind Squirrel Props creates
incredible weapons, helmets and other props
from comics, anime, movies and video games.
Like this Dragon Ball Z Scouter, an AEP7 Laser
Pistol from Fallout, Boromir's Shield from
Lord of The Rings, a Game of Thrones Dragon
Egg, BPRD Pistol from the Hellboy comic, and
this submachine gun.
It comes with step by step directions that
you can download and try yourself.
Draw It
Radiology art was created by physician and
artist Satre Stuelke.
He made them while in medical school because
he wanted to see the interior structures of
everyday objects and ultimately hopes to make
it easier for patients to relate to the radiological
procedures that they go through.
His works include electronics, toys, and even
food.
Thoms creates cool cartoon-like street art.
Some examples of his work include Nerd Power,
My Little Kijo, Right to Housing, and Hair
cut.
Check out his website for more great street
art, sculptures, paintings.
And now for some pieces from the Say Hi To
The Bad Guy art show celebrating Cult Villains...
Michael Paul Smith creates these scenes with
old cars using forced perspective.
By setting up tiny model cars and scenes on
card tables he photographs them from the perfect
angle to seamlessly blend them into the environment.
He's been creating a fictional small town
he calls Elgin Park.
Play It
Uncommon goods sells these major scale musical
wine glasses which sound like this...
One Tesla creates tesla coil kits here's one
playing the theme from Pirates of the Caribbean.
Awesome shredder Eric Calderone aka 331Erock
takes on the music of Spiderman...
Finally here is the video for Infinity Caller
by Grooms with a crowd sourced collaboration
with various animators
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTWO